welcome to this video for the final
round of the Norway 2013 super
tournaments is supreme masters now it's
the ninth round and it looks like Sega
kayaking is going to win this tournament
he is still leading despite losing
second time in round 8 but Carlton also
lost against one how some kayaking still
in the lead but he still needs some
probably at least a draw in the final
round to secure first place so look I'm
let's have a look what happened at first
let's look at her job of against wheeler
both players are not fighting for on the
tournament victory anymore in fact a job
of has a rotten tournament is in fairly
bad form and to me it seems that him
decided beforehand this game that he
really wants to wrap this up and make a
draw and okay he's playing a very sharp
line on paper this porn sec line but in
fact um well being maybe sharp on from
let's say amateur on a normal player
level of you it's a better way to
describe it um it's it's sharp for an
amateur but for professional it seems
that here Bishop g4s them the only move
that is a reliable equalizer for black
or let's say I'm not sure if it is a
complete equalizer but it's it seems
like the most reliable move and here
white can play Bishop rook takes a b7
which already was tested in ronnian
against John Ludwig hammer in this game
Hamid played this move and he wasn't
slide trouble after after d5 and the
best way to answer Ruby seven seems to
be exactly what's witless playing and
this was also recommended in this book
the about the gruene felt by Boris a
Brook the now
standard and most recent work on this
opening he recommended to to grab the
pond and that continues like this here
in fact he recommends roop the aid in
this book but 96 was played and we see
that this is a very very forcing way to
play why just takes only seven looky aid
and Bishop beg and after Bishop to b6
white can go for this attack and like
must oops he'll keep doing that black
must use his good knight on d4 to get
counter play and we see that following
those moves basically everything is
exchanged and also note the opposite
colored bishops white I gave away the
spawn but it doesn't really matter he's
a quick on b3 and two black no plate f5
it really doesn't matter i can also go
rook to e7 and this is also also pretty
dead just the opposite colored bishops
and enter that equal yeah in fact you
played f5 but it's not not much of a
difference giving up the spawn and draw
a grid i think i'm raja before simply
are looking for a line way can simplify
lots of lots of pieces exchanged and
make it wrong he just wanted this
tournament to end and such on paper
sharp line that fizzles out is quite a
good way to do that so draw in this game
um then the next game i'm going to show
is our own yard against cars I'm Runion
against cards yeah aronian cannot win it
anymore and cars and yeah he would need
a win but it seems with black gets it's
a different
both task task against live one you
played the Queens gambit declined very
solid choice no Knight B to D Sanderson
and so so popular but it's a very solid
way to go here you can also play c6
transposing to the Cambridge Springs
this in fact cards played against a girl
found in the candidates he played the
very traditional move Bishop e7 which
leads to the very old-fashioned Queens
gambit declined with NAT bd7 and the
rook see one here played a six this is
really an ancient line clayton the back
in the 20s in game some of let's say
Rubinstein cabo blanco and so on it was
a fairly popular line like 100 years ago
or 80 90 years ago um but the fun thing
is it is still on perfectly all right
for like in fact I'm I studied this a
while back trying to dig out some water
forgotten lines and this a six move on
it's definitely playable the idea is to
take on c4 and then play b5 and I think
if white wants to play for something
here he probably needs to exchange this
is one possibility leading to this
typical cards but structure but with an
early roxy one and A six inserted all
you need to go see five which is the
sharpest move this candy to two very
exciting play something like this is one
possible line a successor move that is
some very interesting to vary in your
play aronian played Queen c2 which is
probably not very testing the reason is
that black now can realize as his main
idea takes
and c5 now be five and this some in fact
I think that this should be two already
shows that white is not fighting for
much if you want to do something you
probably play a four to prevent be five
but one issue is that you look at this
maybe you can play h6 first I'm not sure
if this is more precise the Queen and
rook are not exactly great and an
isolated Queens pawn position at Black
has quite an ordered set up it's
probably about about equal but Aronian
just went back and after b5 played this
maneuver and here i don't think that
black has any sort of problem he has got
this usually problematic bishop now
already developed on a good diagonal and
i think that even why it needs to be
careful and Aronian immediately wraps
the game up i think it's a it's a very
good practical decision you need to make
sure nothing that bad is happening after
this it's very very simplified yeah now
black is threatening all kinds of things
things here like this or roop to see too
so he chose the most most simplifying
option and after a couple more moves
here drawn yes agreed i think one or two
repetitions ok and now a draw yeah a bit
of a disappointing game on cars played a
solid opening but aronian didn't want to
want to fight obviously you can do that
i mean c5 for example as shown is much
sharper so when no i'm not sure how much
you came I can blame cars and for that
for that lifeless draw on the other hand
it's possible that he didn't really want
to
um try too hard risk is too much I mean
he lost a very disappointing game
yesterday against one how and maybe
didn't feel like I'm risking much more
in-depth lose again I don't know it's
also really a matter of both players
moves like Quincy to are simply not
designed to to play for any sort of
advantage so I'm a bit of the dull draw
here okay I'm next game um let's look at
one how against aren't this is actually
relatively easy to commentate on let's
see what happens so we have a
symmetrical English where one how now
place the somewhat uncommon means before
the reason is that after this like
immediately attacks the night and whiter
needs to do something with this needs to
move the night again the normal reaction
would be 92 but this is now
unfortunately met with taking and then
okay it's a matter of move on I think we
need five is the most common move
directly attacking the porn and this
actually am has an excellent reputation
for black it's usually believe that like
even assess better at this position may
be equal but some some guys are already
believe it's it's it's an edge for black
um okay but one how now plate III I
think you just wanted to avoid this
maybe he forgot about this possibility
and now thought okay better not have my
bone structure damaged sorry of course
III needs to position where there's
simply not much happening in fact I'm a
bit surprised if Islands wanted to do
something in this game um I'm a bit
surprised that he's playing for deep
deep sd5 here it's certainly not bad I
mean just from a purely
um yeah just from a mathematical kind of
same point you can you can play that but
if you want to try a bit then i would
rather expect something like this
keeping more pieces on the board esas
like amarok see where there's a three
set up before so black should have a
relatively easy game this is how I
played this number of times and it's
simply delaying the fight and keeping
more pieces on d5 is not bad as
mentioned but it leads to just have a
look to some simplification where it's
not so clear if black has got such a
great position the spawn is weak and
this the squares week you have some
dynamic things going for you this bishop
in particular but it's a matter of test
I didn't I wouldn't like to have this
black if you have this solid alternative
it's a matter of taste I guess now black
has got good active diagonals yeah but
now how plays a very interesting
approach we played this G for taking the
bishop and it doesn't have much choice
back to e6 and now we played a for a
very very concrete play but it's
interesting this simply kicks the night
and after that plans to use the c5
square in plate night to be 495 yeah and
in this position it's already the
probably the decisive position are in
this game I'm here quite shockingly
undertook on a two after about eight
minutes think it could have played them
some other moves I know Queen Queen g6
or a queen move to him to support this
Bishop the simple problem after Bishop
a2 is that Queen a4
threatens uk2 and queen before it's a
simple double attack and I am not quite
sure where but another must have
miscalculated terribly he now played
Queen D for the only move that not
instantly gives away material or you
cannot you can play in something like
this but this kind of position is
basically basically Buster dying just
Bishop here protect this end then you
will add later stage probably windows
pawns it's just um just disaster plate
plate Queen deform yeah it here on white
has the strong north queen a five maybe
I underestimated that one satu tell
which of a to is really a weird move on
so on top player during your just a
terrible terrible bite now with what are
you playing if he removes the bishop for
example there's simply Rick you want and
prepare you go the serve this night is
is just gone I tried I look to the aid
the computer gives this this will move
the ideas after Luke d12 grab on edge hm
this is a really typically crazy
computer stuff of course this is the IDM
flag but white can just move the king
and then Bishop c7 this was the computer
computer idea after Luke d4 though this
should be five look before Bishop before
and then the point tonight a 62 bishops
are hanging and after something like
this White has a technically winning end
game this is in fact very easy it looks
maybe a bit a bit complicated yet but
it's very easy why just goes be three
gypsy for this secures the whole Queen
side then you play Bishop e3 and the
night back and at the end you will win
all those pawns like cannot defend this
you just attack it with all your pieces
and black has no play very easy when
they I played rugby 8 and here one who
played kingi to this is winning um but
he could you could also have played just
look T 1 and this is this is even more
forceful what is black doing now queen
is so just attacked does it have a
square wet keeps before on the board
yeah you need to do this basically okay
my suspicion is that he saw that and
maybe didn't didn't see Queen a form
green a form in fact wins now it's using
this this pin and this probably would
have led to a quick resignation but ok
King g2 also wins it's just preparation
move which allows this move without
checks like Queen d1 Bishop t 1 minus t
1 check and the Sun the thing is black
is so amazingly tied up that he has
absolutely no way to prevent luke t 1 he
simply has no news late Bishop c4 and
now be one end it's still the same
situation like now must give up the
Queen it took on e 2 group takes loop
tags and we should be three and gam it's
still everything's terribly
uncoordinated oopsie for loopy one it
doesn't have a good square needs to take
and now be three look at this rook look
at this night so you need to give even
more stuff
and reach this position where black
basically only has got two bishops for
the Queen the only hope is some very
young crazy some sort of fortress but
it's it's almost impossible to to
achieve so we have found some more moves
they're up there are possibilities for
fortress just just for argument's sake
imagine that um let's say those pieces
would be off the four that I just marked
the rooks are off and those two pawns
off then black positions Bishop on f4
Bishop on e6 and just move kingi a g7
and it's the draw it's a positional draw
and in fact this could be one of those
drawers where the computer thinks white
is winning and he has absolutely no
chances but of course white avoids all
this one how just won this game rather
easily now it's also a matter of
activity and legs pieces are not
coordinated yeah this is the easiest and
now the the B point is the decider note
that blacks bishops is also rather
rather bad yeah here after b5 even anons
resigned yeah this game was really
really bad bye-bye bishop it's somehow
reminded me a lot of the final round
game in an invite on z in generally he
also had a fine tournament Anand and in
the final round he played one how with
black end lost really yeah a really bad
game for his his quality standards this
was even worse I mean Bishop takes a two
was really really weird he must have
miscalculated terribly um yeah I bet a
bad end of this tournament for for our
90 I think he played quite quite a good
tournament after this loss against
Nakamura
yeah me she is just losing too many
games two losses is really a lot for him
okay and one how he managed to after
really terrible start beat Carlton in
round 8 and now i'm not in round nine
this is simply simply amazing okay now
let's have a look at hammer against
Nakamura and yeah John Luke vakama he's
got the the role of the punching bag in
this tournament and everyone wants to
win against him and yeah let's see what
Nakamura is trying to do he needs a win
to have a chance to catch up on first
place and also to just in general um
improve his standing he suddenly wants
to win and he's going for the the
triangle of defense against the default
a very interesting set up against the
Queens gambit this is some intending
various setups one ideas if white plays
III for example you can go into the
stone wall but a stone go over white is
played III and not the g3 set up this is
generally considered to be quite okay
for black after other moves you still
have that option for instance if white
covers this way there's also a five if
you want you don't need to you can
always go back to a semi Slav kind of
setup but you're flexible with UF porn
yeah and another essential ideas if
white goes 93 which is the main move of
course black can take on c4 and this now
is the notorious notable variation on
where black grab c4 and even holds onto
this pawn for a while it least soon
notoriously sharp play this is a really
cool opening to play as black I played
it myself for four years and had
excellent results with it
um I at one point stop to play it
because of some other deviations that I
didn't like so much I didn't like move
like this but from from today's
perspective it's not really clear why I
didn't like it so much I mean black has
pretty decent chances to equalize but he
needs to play Knight f6 and play more
solidly I didn't like it back then okay
but let's go back to the game the
notable III b5 a form Bishop b4 this is
the way it has played white can get the
porn back and he he does in this game as
well a5 and takes pigs pigs v3 so what
initiate initiates this typical counter
play on the on the queenside and will
get his pawn back the ideas after Bishop
bee7bea takes e4 black ass got B form
and this is the feature and on them in
the main characteristics of the notable
variation black gets those two outside
connected passed pawns and white gets an
excellent center and this of course
leads to enormously sharply I mean this
is this is a line which only ends in a
draw normally do to perpetual checks or
or some some weird repetitions otherwise
the drawing rate is basically zero we
see em what's happening white is playing
in the in the normal way he prepares
this movie form here black has some he
black kettle's has a choice back then
when i played this opening i played me
five in this position i remember this
one ideas after the capture which is
questionable weenie like can take on e5
this is quite a good idea what can win
upon him
but just have a look at this kind of
position White has lost all dynamism in
the center and there are still those two
pawns like it's a pond down but yes got
an excellent position a for b3 it's very
difficult to defend against this a
typical scenario in this opening is that
if black has stopped the main play by
white in the center on the King side
then sometimes you're even a piece down
or look down and those pawns are on on
a3 b3 and just head home at the end and
promote yeah this is some bad line for
white of course after the c5 move which
as mentioned i had plate and when i had
this on the board looked like 15 years
ago it's quite a while back that and
then I played that um whites responders
normally helps f4 and after this it
continues but black has got the e-file
as a source of of counter play this is
just an alternative nakamura played
differently plate Quincy seven after
which white can play f4 and block the c5
advance
and now a forum this is very important
you need to get this those pawns rolling
before it's not hanging if white takes
it there's the neat trick Quincy six is
a textbook and threatens made so white
will lose some yea big material it
doesn't lose a rook can play something
like this but okay it's just a piece a
for taking on a force as a huge blunder
and this already meets those pawns are
advancing what the needs to push in the
center but first he sets up his pieces
of it yeah this is also fairly common to
play would be one Bishop they want to
freeze those parts at least a little but
now they cannot move but now quite often
it is it is happening that while being a
piece down or something those pawns are
decisive at the end 26 in fact this
Queen t6 move is a quite a remarkable
decision by McCann right I think he must
have calculated um enormously here or I
simply felt the position very well the
thing is looking at this position now
for white what move would you play it's
not a puzzle I'm just the kind of
question you you ask yourself what would
i play now and the most natural move by
far of course is the most Ephraim we see
that in the game how much playing that
but it seems that this some perfectly
natural move it's felt really possible
that this is a mistake the computer
actually gives bishops III as the only
really good moves in this position one
point is that it protects those pieces
here on the on the D file the idea of
Queen D 6 which is somewhat clumsy
looking move
the idea is quite concrete night c5 if
you play this bishops III move and black
plays 95 there's this funny reply and
this is not what black wants to do of
course you can do that but Weiss has
this has the schools and the 194 right I
skewed up here yeah my notes say 94 I
just read it wrong no this is also it
makes much more sense and now white will
be material without any particular
compensation so Bishop c3 prevents this
95 idea he played before as here as
mentioned and now here it comes 95 this
was my camera's idea of 26 very concrete
play um and what is wyd supposed to do
now and the easiest is taking after
Queen d3y just falls apart efore phones
and and everything it's it's a disaster
also those pawns decide the day cannot
take so what is why it's supposed to do
here yeah he played that I think the the
best and normal movie 5 okay queenie say
needs to go to c6 and now two nights are
hanging what should should white play
now it's of course super complicated i
spent some time to to look at this
position but um it's it's really tricky
to her to analyze and wide whitehead
alternatives by the way he didn't need
to play five but it's of course the the
most principled to apply you can play
other stuff like like rook f3 for
example i had a brief look at that but
i'm not sure that it really helps if
black manages to get rid of this strong
d3 bishop it's it's a huge
accomplishment at this
you form yeah I can play something like
this for example this is designed to
block this diagonal just for argument's
sake something like this would be
terrible at the end because those pawns
are the deciders at the end the central
pawns are not so dangerous they won't
promote but those pawns they have some
promotion potential yeah okay but if
I've was played and I think this is also
the much more natural way to play Queen
c6 in fact i think that the next move he
took on f6 is almost losing it's very
hard to come back after that if at all i
think the critical choice was was to
take on c5 however this leads to an
enormous playful like this is this is
all soaked them but probably it was
still the move to play let's have a look
take and the blacks point is rook to e3
of course white cannot sue capture
because of the the may TM but of course
you can take f6 and of course you should
do that get a piece so how does Anna
camera i'll continue now the most
natural move is rook a 2d one checking
the the night it needs to evacuate to a
three yeah Queen takes and quit f2 and
yeah let's take stock black has some
sacrifice this piece but he's got the
spawns it's um it's really tricky to to
tell I mean it's clear that black ass
enough for the piece I'm not so sure if
he really is better this is the only the
only real question here the moves to
analyze now are taking on f2 and queen
deform
if you take let's let's start with this
this move can analyze this and ok well
happy that they are strong those bonds
but they do they really win if you look
at something like this root g one g six
and now you use your own see phone it's
not so clear to me if this is which is
really sorry i think i can I screwed up
here GF a three-book g one g 60 this is
the line i prepared sorry c5 and now I'm
there's a month others a to ok something
like this ok
yeah something like this you can even
continue to analyze probably it's a
drone at the end but it's cost far from
being frost I just want to show that
there's lots of complicated things to to
analyze after Queen f2 there's also quit
before which is maybe even the buttons
but it's a it's also i'm very
complicated there are their ideas for
white them like simply taking but also
of f5 for example try to use the f file
its own it's hard to tell i think in a
practical game like it's an excellent
shape there's no doubt about that I'm
not so sure about the objective value
maybe white can in fact defend but it's
um it's it's very difficult a quick
alternative to mention is after he takes
f6 to immediately capture on c5 it'sit's
maybe we can but it's interesting and it
involves a little trap that white now
tries this black is winning with rube t2
it's useful motive to to remember takes
ok ok and black wins the house what
needs to play the the funny of Queen d5
now and yeah of course like it's winning
very easily here so Queen f2 it is not
possible at all i wanted to show this
idea um yeah something like Google I
have to probably needs to be played and
after that look the eight is somewhat
different to be formed here white can
can go a night f1 and I must go night f1
on on a moon flag Knight f3 there's a
three and those pawns will decide
so not everyone and now there are
various ideas you can go here g6 or you
can even grab the spawn it's a
completely messy position that I cannot
assess really um for in the practical
game I'd easily say that like is okay at
least but it's rather tough to analyze I
think that in comparison probably worked
the ages the the better lúthien but okay
very complicated but what I think needed
to do that in the game he took on f6 and
night XD 3 and now we have the same
situation of a piece capturing on d3
that cannot be taken because of the maid
and yeah what what is why it's supposed
to do now I think that with rook f3 he
could have continued to to put up a good
fight attacking the night and um after
after this night c5 move again yeah we
have a similar position to before this
is just one impossibility with the with
this sort of weird compensation position
for black black can also go be too and
maybe I'll night before not before maybe
I didn't analyze the smooth but it
doesn't doesn't look too bad yeah the
point is I think he needed to go look at
three simply because the other move i
justjust not playable he played their
queen to g4 and after g6 Luke f3 black
and played be too and this enjoying a
really a substantial edge this was was
played and here the big point as if
white takes on d3 you didn't do that if
Y takes like a Scott v takes a one Luke
takes and now the point rook takes
deform this is very very nice white
takes and to Quincy five this is just
very strong using this pin white cannot
move the night anyway like him just grab
and win both looks even in this case so
f five is needed and then you just go
look the eight and grab before with the
winning position I'm quite a quite a
nice line so it you play the Queen g5
trying to hang on takes and Queen B 6
this is strong before I saying Queen B
to as an idea and yeah like us at the
moment the piece up so white needs to
get the night back here look deformed
and now this is just terrible threat
this this whatever all kinds of um
discover checks so we play group b 1 and
after the return like when Sir
a whole bunch of material the last
bullet group takes f7 but black helm can
just basically know that check check
again and take this this is the easiest
way to go and hear how I resigned after
King takes you can everyone just insert
a check and then promote this there is
no no counter check really that white
can go for if you go something like this
yeah yeah yeah yeah you made it in this
way yeah very nice game by Nakamura I
think windy 6 was an excellent move
really I wonder and let's let's I wonder
how much time you spend on that there
are more than 20 minutes 22 minutes y an
excellent decision setting up this
counter play and he really must have a
thing calculated this very nicely with
with the peace sacrifice so I well
deserved win for for Nakamura and this
means he has a good result anyway
whatever cariocans is doing in this game
he's got at the end the plus to score if
i'm not mistaken I helpful I put up the
the the final standings after I showed
the last game so I'm a good tournament
for Hikaru so um only the leaders game
kayaking took all of his boots mm-hmm
didn't want to do that sorry
this was my analysis board is it
kayaking to Bravo here we go and okk
Aachen leading the tournament I think a
draw would suit him fine but he's an e4
player and it's not the type to play
some sidelines so we haven't so we have
a night off with Bishop g5 and in fact
tupolev plays a sharp line that you
cannot easily force a draw against in
fact after some lines let's say let's
say in the the poison horn here white
can in some lines basically draw at will
and just force a draw with very concrete
claim and the pile of is not belong that
he is playing the quick Quincy 7 and
this is one of those um vicious fighting
lines where black tries to quickly
attack on the on the queenside the
drawback is that after this capture you
have a damaged bone structure this is
very similar to them on to the rouser
with the Bishop g5 96 the differences
that here there's no knight on c6 and
this can often help like let's have a
look at the game yeah now the night here
the night can set up post on on on b6
where it has ideas to go on c4 and it
controls the crucial square on d5 we see
that kayaking now plays the move came be
one and after Knight b6 he goes f5 this
is a very typical way to to play him
this structure he wants to pressurize e6
and force this pawn to move which
happened
but there is a difference to lots of
other positions of this type Black has
got quite good control over d5 the night
is just a good piece on b6 controlling
the square and why it has a hard time to
reposition his pieces that you can
actually use the square and it feels
just a couple of moves in design 95 is
questionable maybe but yeah i'm not sure
what what why should play to be honest
and i play one before in my blitz games
once in a while to have some very
variety and in them but i have no idea
how to play the open the sodium that's
white I mean not in a knot on a decent
level and frankly speaking I'm a bit bit
unsure what white should do now and what
I'm pretty sure of that 95 is not so
great but i'm not sure what white should
do um I don't know maybe you can somehow
reposition this night I am I don't like
the night much on b3 it's just looking
at squares that are controlled but um
it's it's hard to tell I'm not a great
expert in the open Sicilian the
structures and and everything what I
don't like about 95 is ok black took it
with the bishop and now play Bishop to
h6 Queen moves Nancy for what i don't
like about this position is that white
doesn't have any positive active plan
now available it's very difficult now to
to make any sort of progress you cannot
really play on the Kings side and take
this to consideration the next couple of
moves let's look at this you cannot play
on the Kings side this is a very sound
defensive wall and this is a good piece
of naan
if it controlled support diagonal and on
the queenside when you cannot open the
queenside your king is over there so
frankly speaking I don't see a plan for
white you can basically just shuffle
around and this is in fact what happened
they shuffled around a lot wyd
reposition this night to better control
before so he's ready for this advanced
and both sides trying to improve pieces
a bit of course you can analyze this in
much more detail if you if you like but
I'd like to focus on on one or two
critical moments here exactly here I
think that the next move but Apollo is
it's not the best one at least this is
what the computer assisted analysis on
broad AB he played kingdon and later on
a night to see form it seems that night
a for here is a good idea the ideas to
put pressure on both those pawns and
maybe in some cases being able to
sacrifice on be too I think white
probably should cover the pawn on c3 if
you play as some other moves let's say
this one black can't consider to take
and it's probably a good line
here black has the funny move Bishop see
one threatening mate rook takes rook g4
and now if white takes 23 wins for black
is everything hanging now see to
everything so wyd needs to do something
else probably here and now maybe this
maneuver I think black is an excellent
shape here probably winning so why it
shouldn't allow that he probably should
on my day for playbook d3 and here i
just want to show a sample line and
black is simply increasing the pressure
slowly like this for example queen d one
queen b 6 and this is the intention to
even play a roxy form let's say Queenie
one looks you for Bishop f3 Quincy five
just increasing the pressure more and
more and this can get ugly rather rather
quickly let's say just just for
argument's sake it's not forced and now
this idea I think why this is white is
in some trouble after not a four it's
especially difficult to play because
black is black is not like storming your
king is just creeping towards your king
slowly shuffling pieces towards towards
your your king and attacking slowly this
is sometimes more dangerous than those
those very direct attacks where you see
okay is going there how how how do I
defend against that you only have one
move you play it you defend but he had
sort of a slow crawl towards your king
um it's possible that white is in real
trouble them after King d7 kayaking
managed to do this Bishop d3 and after
night safari could take and initiate
this counter play due to the pin so
black
take this is a now see for saying this
means that this part got lost but it's
not the end of the world for black of
course black has got excellent pressure
here and they they shuffled a bit I mean
white has no chance whatsoever to do
anything he's just tied to the defense
iam but to part off is playing round
booty and tries to do something this is
just shuffling but the couple of Hoops
later you was trying to do something
with this in fact and yeah okay I can
flip the best move Quincy to attacking a
four and now it it gets briefly
interesting again if black takes you
just take a form and this is some
progress why it's not clear like is this
situation so I can can just press
without any risk just look at this if
like now let's say place d 52 to attack
you have a four and tricks like that
this can easily fall apart for like you
played some other move leave me this 92
back now played rook a five yeah here if
like a black takes here there's root a
phone and it's not so clear that this is
still enough for black youporn down you
played this one or ever enter here we
have a clear case of a specific
tournament situation in this position
Kuryakin could have played the movie
form which very likely is excellent for
white he should be in very good shape it
has definite winning chances but he em
he spotted that after now
c4 look back night back there's a
repetition and okay they repeated moves
and no agreed to draw I think I ucking
just saw ok I can draw now and he was I
think very well aware that he wasn't
slight trouble before he lost in round 8
and the drawer secures the win at this
point the other games were finished
Arnold lost and Carlton did win and so
on he was short with a draw I'm the the
sole winner of this thing so he took the
draw a very very a decent practical
decision it's just for a couple of
rating points you don't need to risk too
much just win the tournament he hasn't
won a tournament for four years like two
years or so I think he won why not too
long ago my camera I think one in 2011
Ronan in 12 I'm not quite sure but
coyoacán I don't think he he won one of
the big big classical time control
tournaments recently and I think he's
glad to to have this this really fine
result um I'd like to pull up the final
standings briefly this is the final
standings we can see that coyoacán is
the winner he lost two games against
Carlton and against swidler but still
won the tournament would have a point
ahead so we want five games at the end
scoring a plus three score very nice and
yeah they don't have an an an e lo
result like waiting game until suddenly
gained a number of number of points here
so do like 15 points or so then we have
carson and nakamura both on 5.5 points
five and a half point nakamura lost two
games against kayaking and Aronian but
also won four games plus two very good
result and Carlton yep is this some
basically playing
according to his I think rating um
expectation but he's certainly
disappointed about this loss against one
how even a draw would have secured first
place at this time I think you would
have had the better the better tie break
yeah then we have sweedler aronia and
are not all on plus one in case of
sweetland aronian yeah they won't be
thrilled but also won't be am disgusted
with the result I think yeah be she
certainly must be disappointed with the
final game against Ron how he played a
decent enough tournament beating to haul
off in a nice game beating my job off so
he am he did at the game against Tom I
also liked it was a good to good fight
yeah one how had great games and and and
really bad games he's very inconsistent
but yeah he beat the world champion and
he beat cars and so very nice end of the
tournament just imagine you wouldn't
have those two wins in the last two
rounds then he was would have had to
robin tournament yet to pull off without
a win the only player in the tournament
without a win always a bit frustrating
he lost this one game against Vichy and
drew the rest bit of an unspectacular
tournament he was in pretty good shape
lately but somehow didn't show him yeah
raja baath is in very bad shape no idea
why only one the one game against hammer
and got really beaten up by the other
guys yeah and the john not become a 1-1
game I think he's very glad about that
and drew against to Parliament lost the
rest it's a I guess I can only imagine
I'm not in a situation never been in a
similar situation I can only imagine how
it must be that basically every play and
the field is like 150 points above you
it's a the comparison would be like me
playing against a couple of guys that I
don't know to 562 5 450 is something
like that you have a hard time in every
game and if it's not working out and
you're not in excellent shape for
whatever reason then you really get get
so many losses so we he won't be
thrilled but it's um it can happen if
you play only the the best place in the
world okay this is the end of the the
tournament coverage I hope you enjoyed
it i think it was a very entertaining
tournament we had lots of decisive
results it's really a rarity that
someone wins the tournament who has lost
two games so we see that they fought a
lot yeah thanks for watching this video
and also the videos before view um and a
look at this thanks and yeah i'm not
quite sure the next big tournament i
think will be the tal memorial in in
june and i think i'll come with that as
well yeah bye